في العام الماضي نشر الملياردو
مركبه اطلق عليها اسم سفينه نوحي الفضائيه
وقال انها ستحمل زوجين من جميع الكائنات
الى المريخ اذا حصل الانقراض السادس في
الارض اعلان عده البعض ضربا من الجنون
واصر ماسك على ان الانقراض قادم لا محاله
فهل حقا تقترب البشريه من الفناء وما قصه
الانقراض السادس الذي يتربص بكوكبنا
وحيد القرن الاسود وسلحفاه البنتا وطائر
سبيكس ماكاو الجميل هذه الحيوانات كلها لن
تراها الا في الصور بعد الان ببساطه لانهم
انقرضت نهائيا خلال سنوات العشر الماضيه
فقط وهي من اصل سته عشر الف نوع تنقرض
بوتيره سريعه جدا في ظاهره خطيره يعدها
العلماء دليلا دامغا على دخول نظامنا
البيئي مرحله لانقراض الجماعي
شهدتها الارض خلال 500 مليون سنه البدايه
بالانقراض الاردوفيشي الذي تحولت به الارض
الى كتله جليد بسبب تغير مناخي عظيم قضى
على خمسه
من الكائنات الحيه ثم الانقراض الديفوني
الذي يعتقد ان سببه جسم اصطدم بالارض
واحدث تغيرا فوضويا في المناخ وتلاهم
انقراض العصر البرني الثالث الذي قضى على
96% من الكائنات وكان سببهم في جارات
بركانيه هائله في سيبيريا ثم الانقراض
الترياسي الجوراسي الذي يعتقد ان هناك عن
تصحر الارض بسبب موجات حراره عنيفه واخيرا
الانقراض الخامس الطباشيري الثلاثي حدث
قبل 66 مليون سنه ونتج عن اصطدام كويكب
بالارض وقضى على ثلاثه ارباع الكائنات
الحيه
وعلى راسها الديناصورات
وبعد حالات الفناء الخمس لم يتاخر كوكبنا
عن التعافي والانتعاش ولدت كائنات جديده
اعادت الى الارض تنوعها البيئي واحيتها من
جديد لكن احد هذه المخلوقات سيكون له
تاثير عكسي يسيم في هدم الكوكب تماما مثل
ما فعل اصطدام الكويكب من تتوقع ان يكون
هذا الكائن انه الانسان
لا يعرف العلماء تاريخا دقيقا لظهور البشر
على الارض لكن معظم الدراسات تقدر ان
تاريخ الحضاره البشريه يتراوح بين سته
الاف وعشره الاف سنه
لمعرفه مدى خطوره افعال البشر على الارض
لابد من العوده الى السر وراء الانقراضات
السابقه السمه الابرز التي صاحبت اسوا
ثلاثه انقراضات جماعيه كانت تحمض المحيطات
ومنذ اواخر ثمانينيات القرن الماضي بدات
حمضيه المحيطات في الارتفاع بمقدار
0.2 كل عقد وفقا لتقرير صدر عام 2019 من
اللجنه الدوليه المختصه بشؤون تغير المناخ
تحدث ظاهره التحمض نتيجه انحلال ثاني
اكسيد ملوث الهواء الاساس والمسبب الرئيسي
للاحتباس الحراري
وفي الوقت الحالي تسجل نسبه ثاني اكسيد
الكربون في الجو معدلات لم تحدث منذ 800
الف سنه
وبحلول نهايه القرن الحالي اي بعد سبع
وسبعين عاما سيصل ثاني اكسيد الكربون الى
مستويات لم تحدث منذ 15 مليون سنه الوقود
الاحفوري الذي يحرقه الانسان يتصدر قائمه
اسباب الخلل بهذه المعدلات الخطيره
قبل ظهور التكنولوجيا والوقود لم يكن
الانسان القديم بريئا من العبث بمستقبل
الارض اقتلع البشر غابات واسعه عن عمد
للحصول على الطعام
وتعمدوا ايضا نقل الكائنات الحيه من قاره
الى اخرى واعادوا تشكيل الغلاف الحيوي
فتناقصت اعداد حيوانات وحشرات اساسيه بسبب
القبض الجائر او عدم التكيف وشقه انهار
مسارات غير طبيعيه بسبب السدود واسهمت
مصانع الاسمده في ضخ النيتروجين بقدر يفوق
طاقه الارض
يكاد يغيب التفاؤل بين العلماء عند الحديث
عن الانقراض السادس متوسط حراره سطح الارض
يتفاوت حاليا بين 1.5 وواحد فاصل ثمانيه
درجه مئويه وسيصل في نهايه القرن الحالي
الى 4.4 درجات واذا تخطت درجات الحراره
حاجزه 5.2 فسيؤدي ذلك الى انقراض جماعي
بحري كبير لعدم قدره الكائنات الحيه على
الانسجام مع التغير الجديد ويتكرر بذلك ما
حصل في الانقراضات الخمسه الكبرى السابقه
مع توقعات بان يكون مستوى الفناء اقل من
السابق دراسه للعالم الياباني كونيو تقدم
سيناريو اكثر تفائلا وتقول ان الانقراض
السادس لم يحدث قبل ان ترتفع درجه الحراره
بنحو 9 درجات مئويه ولم يحدث هذا حتى عام
2500 في اسوا الاحوال
ومع كل هذا الثور يؤكد العلماء ان الخطر
ليس محتوما وما تزال هناك فرصه لانقاذ
الارض ولما كان الانسان هو المتسبب في
الكوارث المحدقه فانه الكائن الوحيد الذي
يحمل مفتاح النجاه
وتدور كل الدراسات حول ركيزه اساس لاطاله
عمر الارض ومنع اسباب الانقراض وهي الحفاظ
على درجه حراره الارض والحد من انبعاثات
ثاني اكسيد الكربون ويضع علماء المناخ خطه
تتحقق اهدافها في مرحلتين الاولى في عام
2030 وتقوم على اتفاق اكثر من 200 دوله
لتحقيق 20 هدفا
في مقدمتها الحد من تراجع التنوع
البيولوجي الذي يحصل بسبب تدمير الغابات
المطيره والتلوث وتعقب هذه المرحله خطه
ثانيه تبدا بوقف الاستخدام التقليدي
للطاقه والاعتماد على الشمس والرياح
لتوليد الطاقه الكهربائيه للتخلي عن
الوقود بنسبه 70% بحلول عام 2050 بعدها
سيعلن العلماء التقييم النهائيا للنتائج
فاما تتجاوز الارض الخطر المحدق واما نبحث
جميعا عن مقعد في مركبه ايلون ماسك
[موسيقى]